[Música]
en mi mente
barcos chinos perseguidos por pescadores
locales en irán
[Música]
en yibutí o en general
en casos de sobrepesca a menudo ilegales
grabados por nuestros observadores en
todo el mundo el objetivo es denunciar
las técnicas industriales pues tienen
consecuencias desastrosas para el medio
ambiente y la economía
en los últimos 50 años la mitad de todas
las poblaciones marinas han desaparecido
debido a las actividades humanas
detrás de este desastre ecológico se
encuentra la pesca industrial practicada
por muchos países japón corea del sur
españa francia
pero sobre todo por china la mayor flota
pesquera del mundo y el principal
exportador de productos del mar barcos
que a veces rozan los límites de la
legalidad lejos de las miradas
[Música]
las comunidades locales tratan de luchar
grabando estos abusos con sus teléfonos
con la esperanza de preservar los
ecosistemas así como su fuente de
alimentos e ingresos
[Música]
y gracias a las nuevas tecnologías
pudimos rastrear estos barcos
[Música]
barcos industriales capturando toneladas
de pescado la escena fue grabada este
verano en las islas galápagos
clasificadas como patrimonio de la
humanidad por la unesco debido a la
riqueza de sus ecosistemas marinos
tiburones martillo tortugas gigantes
leones marinos y pingüinos estos barcos
pesqueros chinos navegaban cerca de la
frontera marítima a 350 kilómetros de la
costa invisibles desde la orilla pero no
pasó mucho tiempo antes de que los
locales detectaron su presencia
especialmente este año hemos encontrado
muchas botellas chinas plástico las
botellas de agua
sabía por todos lados en las islas en la
mayoría de los lugares las trajo la
corriente podrían verse en las rocas sin
las playas
se apilaban y se acumulan era muy triste
y los pescadores también notaron
rápidamente un impacto en su oficio este
es el caso de donato rendón
el esposo de nuestra observadora y von
torres quien ha estado pescando en las
islas galápagos desde hace más de 30
años
demasiado sofistica
ya son ya de mil dos mil toneladas
se llevan todas las
que tenemos aquí en este santuario
marino
de la gala
de castilla de
de peces dentro de la reserva porque ya
ahora por ejemplo uno sale por dos o
tres días y se queda hasta cinco o seis
días para poder obtener
la presencia de estos barcos aumenta la
contaminación del agua y afecta a los
animales del archipiélago estos
especímenes únicos en el mundo son el
motor de la industria turística local
fuente de sustento para los residentes
de la isla y para los guías como ibón
torres de los peces se comen el plástico
se comen el nylon todas esas cosas
acaban en sus estómagos y nosotros nos
comemos todo eso
y cada vez tenemos menos peces lo que
significa que cada vez habrá menos aves
especialmente aves marinas que son uno
de los principales atractivos de las
islas galápagos ingala silence
también tenemos menos tiburones lo que
seguramente afectará a nuestro atractivo
turístico veo menos animales en las
islas es preocupante
el anses working
[Música]
tratamos de averiguar más sobre esta
flota china a través de la página web
global fishing watch
global es una página que rastrea los
barcos de pesca industrial de todo el
mundo según las regulaciones
internacionales cualquier barco de más
de 300 toneladas lo cual corresponde al
tamaño de un arrastrero como éste debe
transmitir una señal con su ubicación
permanentemente esta señal se puede ver
en esta página
aquí por ejemplo podemos ver la ruta de
un barco atunero ecuatoriano de mayo a
julio nos quisimos identificar y
rastrear los barcos chinos cada color
corresponde a un barco de pesca
aquí nos vemos a lo largo de la frontera
marítima al sur de las islas galápagos
tienen cuidado de no cruzarla pero se
acercan mucho a veces a tan solo dos
kilómetros de distancia
en esta página en ningún momento se les
ve entrar en las aguas territoriales del
archipiélago o de ecuador
pudimos rastrear 170 barcos con bandera
china
[Música]
pero los analistas
a veces ha habido hasta 350 barcos
incluyendo buques de suministro de
combustible incluyendo a bomberos
marcus frigoríficos o
hay una mezcla de barcos allá
principalmente barcos de pesca de
calamares esta flota utiliza potentes
luces para calmar a la superficie y
capturarlo pero también hay algunos
barcos que apoyan a esta flota ya sea
para reabastecerlos de combustible o
para trasladar el pescado capturado al
puerto lo que les permite a los barcos
quedarse para seguir pescando
pudimos rastrear este barco frigorífico
aquí está recuperando la carga de dos
barcos de pesca de calamares se puede
alcanzar a ver su nombre el yongxiang 9
este buque de más de 9 mil toneladas
lleva la bandera panameña pero es
manejado por una compañía con sede en
hong kong recuperó la pesca de al menos
15 barcos cerca de las islas galápagos
no hay manera de saber exactamente a
cuántos barcos apoyó porque su señal gps
fue desactivada cinco días antes de que
fuera grabado lo cual es ilegal para una
embarcación tan grande
reapareció un mes después a 16.000
kilómetros de distancia en un puerto
chino regreso agua y hai a finales de
agosto este complejo industrial
portuario alberga la mayor unidad de
procesamiento de calamares del país 200
mil toneladas de calamares son lavados
cortados y congelados cada año su
destino de china otros países asiáticos
pero también francia españa y eeuu
que un barco pueda ver si significa que
esté pescando ilegalmente en su mayoría
es pesca regulada lo que también puede
haber actividades ilegales la dificultad
radica en determinar quién tiene una
autorización que no lo sea ya quién no
qué es lo que realmente pesca se captura
accesoria de tiburones esta no es la
primera vez que los barcos chinos se
acercan a las islas galápagos para
pescar en 2017 el ejército ecuatoriano
incautó este buque en la reserva con 300
toneladas de pescado a bordo incluyendo
6 mil tiburones su tripulación fue
sentenciado a la prisión por retener y
transportar ilegalmente especies
protegidas cuando se tiene un lugar tan
delicado como las galápagos acerca de
estos barcos están pescando tenemos que
ser capaces de la extracción de los
peces no está dañando aquello que se
creó la reserva en algún lugar alguien
tiene que asumir la responsabilidad de
esta flota y asegurarse que no exploten
los recursos de forma inapropiada
esta impresionante flota es solo un
ejemplo entre muchos nuestros
observadores en irán jibuti y áfrica
occidental nos han alertado desde hace
varios años sobre la sobrepesca y las
prácticas dudosas de los buques chinos
desde la costa de mauritania hasta el
golfo de guinea se cree que el 40 por
ciento del pescado capturado es ilegal
lo que impacta directamente a las 7
millones de personas que dependen de él
para su sustento y alimentación
[Música]
estas imágenes fueron tomadas en las
costas de costa de márfil por pescadores
marfileños contratados a bordo de un
arrastrero chino
[Música]
dicen que este gran delfín gris una
especie protegida fue almacenado y
transportado a bordo del barco lo cual
es un crimen
en esta área
estos pescadores marfileños se enviaron
muchos otros vídeos al equipo editorial
de los observadores para denunciar la
sobreexplotación de los recursos
pesqueros
ya me cansé grabé esto para mostrárselo
a la comunidad internacional esto es lo
que está pasando en las aguas de costa
de marfil estos peces son bebés miren
todo el pescado son toneladas
el capitán son de ayuda uy es el
portavoz de los pescadores los
pescadores están hartos de los barcos
chinos de que no respeten el descanso
biológico que es cuando se detiene la
pesca para que las especies se
reproduzcan así que eso altera un poco
el equilibrio del ecosistema marino
y cuando uno ve que los barcos chinos
vienen a pescar y se llevan toda la
pesca que capturaron en el espacio
territorial de costa de marfil y la
envían directamente a china hay un
problema mientras que para nosotros ya
es difícil abastecer el mercado local
cuando decimos barcos chinos nos
referimos a barcos con bandera marfileña
pero con tripulación china es un barco
chino
ahí vemos a uno de los capitanes
los barcos tienen nombres chinos como hi
lux
ron chang yong hyun el capitán de pesca
es chino el patrón de pesca es chino el
maquinista es chino y los otros miembros
de la tripulación los marineros son
todos africanos eso va en contra del
código marítimo de costa de marfil el
30% de la tripulación debe ser marfileña
incluyendo los oficiales según nuestro
observador
ninguna de las 55 embarcaciones en
cuestión respeta esa regla
otra vez vamos a trabajar por la noche
[Música]
hay una mafia que lleva años trabajando
en contra de los intereses de nuestros
pescadores
de los 80 barcos pesqueros con base en
el puerto de abiyán 55 son administrados
por empresas conjuntas empresas
registradas en costa de márfil
administradas por ciudadanos chinos
es así como los barcos obtienen
licencias de pesca y navegan bajo la
bandera de costa de marfil al tratar de
rastrear los en línea notamos que casi
ninguno había activado su localizador
gps como este el hi lufeng 11 propiedad
de la empresa conjunta hai na esto es
ilegal para una embarcación de este
tamaño en junio de 2020 las autoridades
nigerianas le pusieron una multa de
7.800 dólares a la empresa estas
prácticas comunes en toda la región en
particular en senegal y mauritania
tienen graves consecuencias el 50 por
ciento de las especies está
sobreexplotado una de las tasas más
altas del mundo
como otros pescadores de la región
nuestro observador denuncia la
permisividad de los gobiernos africanos
hacia los barcos extranjeros
la última vez que se hicieron críticas
públicas contra china fue en diciembre
de 2015
en ese momento 24 estados africanos le
habían pedido a beijing detener la pesca
ilegal sabemos que muchos de estos
barcos chinos han sido señalados a nivel
subregional en actos de pesca y nn es
decir ilegal no declarada y no
reglamentada porque reducen la apertura
de las masas capturan especies que no
están en las licencias capturan especies
protegidas pescan en zonas donde es
prohibido esto que está pasando ahora en
costa de márfil se pasó en gana y el
nivel ya está empezando a suceder en
general este recurso ha sido
completamente diezmado por todos esos
grandes barcos que están allá gran parte
de la pesca actual se transforma en
harina de pescado destinada a alimentar
a los animales en europa o asia o
incluso alimentar a los peces de
criadero matan a los peces en áfrica
para alimentar a los peces en europa o
en asia es muy grave no debemos olvidar
que en nuestros países de áfrica
occidental muchas de nuestras
poblaciones obtienen la proteína animal
del pescado ya sea procesado seco o
ahumado
la seguridad alimentaria de estas
poblaciones está amenazada las
consecuencias lo que está pasando con la
inmigración ilegal porque cuando el
pescador se desaniman cuando siente que
ya no puede ganarse la vida con su
producto que piensa se dice a sí mismo
tengo que dejar este trabajo es lo único
que sé hacer así que tengo que irme del
país
en las últimas semanas miles de
senegaleses y mauritanos han llegado al
archipiélago español de las islas
canarias en estas piraguas
entre ellos muchos pescadores